[Music]
in this its characteristic work absolute
freedom becomes explicitly objective to
itself and self-consciousness learns
what absolute freedom in effect is in
itself it is just this abstract
self-consciousness which faces all
distinction and all continuance of
distinction within it it is as such that
it is objective to itself the terror of
death is the vision of this negative
nature of itself but absolutely free
self-consciousness finds this it's
reality quite different from what its
own notion of itself was that is that
the universal will is merely the
positive essence of personality and that
this latter knows itself in it only
positively or is preserved there in here
however this self-consciousness which is
pure inside completely separates its
positive and its negative nature
completely separates the predicate less
absolute as pure thought and as pure
matter is confronted with the absolute
transition of the one into the other as
a present reality the universal will qua
absolutely positive actual self
consciousness because it is this self
conscious reality heightened to the
level of pure thought or of abstract
matter changes round into its negative
nature and shows itself to be equally
that which puts on an end to the
thinking of oneself or to
self-consciousness
in paragraph 592 we're seeing one key
set of movements in the ALF hey bong the
the sublation is how we translate it in
English
that's occurring in this passage and we
need to remind ourselves that for Hegel
at each point that there is a transition
to a new shape of consciousness like the
one that we're going to be transitioning
to and just a few paragraphs from now
there is always a negative moment of you
could say critique or surpassing or
opposing and conquering but there's
always a reincorporation of that you you
never come back to exactly the same
starting point that you originally began
with and then left there's always some
transition and gain in the process here
in this passage Hegel's talking in very
abstract terms so we need to help
ourselves out and think about what the
reference of these are in terms of the
historical moment that he sees as so
central this you know transition that's
taking place through the French
Revolution choose something like
absolute freedom and then the working
out for itself in practice what absolute
freedom really is he begins this this
paragraph in a way that you might find a
little bit enigmatic if you dwell on it
because it's very easy just to pass over
this first sentence in this its
characteristic work absolute freedom
becomes explicitly objective to itself
self-consciousness learns what absolute
freedom in effect is and if you're just
focusing on the second third part of
that passage right absolute freedom is
learning is becoming explicitly
objective to itself and we'll talk about
the translation of that in just a moment
and self-consciousness learns what
absolute freedom in effect is you'll
so ver this reference to a a work the
german term for that is simply vodka
right and this is something that has
been accomplished something that has
been produced and you could say well
what is that we're looking back at the
previous paragraph what what is it is it
death is that this cold matter-of-fact
annihilation of the existent self very
particular but also in some respects
particulate you know quality less kind
of death is that the being suspected is
that this interplay of government and
faction and rising up against it sort of
a deal Ajith amis ation of the very
thing that was supposed to solve this
problem of legitimacy the transition
from the general or universal will into
particular will what is this this work
that Hegel is referring to and I think
here we actually need to think of all of
these combined into one dynamic this
work this thing that has been
accomplished is both what the government
itself does and its opposition in other
individuals other factions and then this
spread of universal suspicion which then
leads to killing that's part of it all
right but because Hegel is saying that
that you know both absolute freedom and
self-consciousness are acquiring
something in the process we also have to
look at this as the work the
accomplishment of world spirit taking
place through this this you know
revolution and then the terror that that
follows after that I'd also like to
dwell on something too so this is
important to keep in mind Hegel had
brought up suspicion in the previous
paragraph and now he's going to talk
about learning something through
negativity now he's been focusing on a
death that the government imposes or
factions imposed upon each other and all
sorts of victims in the process and it's
a death that is is particularly
terroristic in that it reduces
individuals in their meaning down to
mere nothings heads of cabbage to be cut
off we might think about some of the
terrible atrocities that took place on
the part of totalitarian governments we
can also think of the sort of terror
that took place whether there was in
effect a kind of reigning Anarchy that
was allowing a space for violent often
you know racist lis motivated groups to
try to enforce their power you could
think for example of the terror involved
here in the United States through
lynching and the fact that legal
enforcement of the you know sort of
Universal realm of law against that
failed over and over and over again to
the extent where entire communities
could be wiped out particularly if they
they stood too high so this is not
something just about to tell us Aryan
governments this is something that that
happens over and over again
now terror works by not killing
everybody
if you kill everybody then from a
dialectical standpoint you go back to
start you have to find new individuals
who then you can inculcate in whatever
way you want it's sort of like the
master-slave dialectic or the struggle
to the death if the you know the two
consciousness is meet and the one kills
the other well go back to start however
in the master-slave dialectic one
consciousness imposes a sort of regime
on the other and it does through so it
does so through fear right that's
exactly what Hegel says in that point of
the phenomenology and we've encountered
this at
several other places now
this absolute suspicion is a suspicion
of the other that they are going to
abuse their power that they are you know
guilty of something and therefore you
can use force against them but it's also
a suspicion that they will use that
power on you and so there's this dynamic
of suspecting and being suspected
insofar as you can be suspected by
somebody else during the terror you are
in some respects as good as dead except
you're stuck there in that half life
feeling the fear that perhaps your life
might be snuffed out like that at any
moment as soon as the guards come for
you and take you to the guillotine on
the other hand you as a human agent are
also inducing that suspicion in others
so we have a very complex dynamic here
all of this is wrapped up in this term
work right so let's come back now to the
sentence in this absolute freedom an
absolute freedom is in essence the
government in this case right it starts
out as like you know liberty fraternity
equality for all men and of course you
know not for women as Mary
Wollstonecraft had to point out within
her you know vindication of the rights
of women addressed to the education who
believes secretary who is attempting to
impose this absolute freedom across the
board in terms of Education for men but
leaving women out be that as it may
let's say it was totally across the
board absolute freedom absolute freedom
degenerates into or rather develops into
the universal will taking the shape of a
particular will in doing so Hegel says
it becomes the translation here is it
becomes explicitly objective to itself
and you know the the the German is
actually that it just becomes object to
itself it become makes itself into an
object something not just that can be
manipulated like a knob
but can be understood by itself in an
objective fashion and it does so through
this work and this work is something I
should have put this here it is
something that it imposes on
self-consciousness right
self-consciousness
for its own part whether it's the
self-consciousness of those who are in a
privileged position of governance or the
self-consciousness of the person who
becomes the victim or the
self-consciousness of the person who's
observing this or the self-consciousness
of the person who works as a tool in the
machine all these are different
possibilities learns the translation
says learns what it is that absolute
freedom is going to be and it learned
that it's it's tyrannical in some
respect right now learn here is a
translation of their farts all right and
if Fong you know if iron this comes from
the you know the sort of core of this is
foreign which has to do with like taking
a journey this is not something that
it's learning from a book it's learning
by experiencing it and then reflecting
upon that experience and perhaps
engaging in discourse about it so that's
all for the first sentence let's go on
with the rest right he says in itself
absolute freedom is just this abstract
self-consciousness which faces all
distinction and all continuance of
distinction within it and one way to
face that is precisely by imposing death
or inducing this realm of suspicion
hey Google's on Tony says it is as such
that it is objective to itself and here
he clearly connects it with death he
says the terror of death is the vision
of this negative nature of itself
everybody within the society has to
endure this terror of death and not just
a death that you know is a happy death
at home with your family gathered around
you know whispering some last words of
wisdom to them know it's a death of the
taken out to the field and shot in the
back of the head or brought in front of
the guillotine and having everybody say
terrible things about you before the
blade comes down and then you just
having your body tossed into the sin or
wherever else you know the things are
taking place so he goes on and he says
absolutely free self consciousness finds
this it's reality quite different from
what its own notion of itself was who's
absolutely free self consciousness well
everybody within the society I mean
those slogans freedom liberty right
equality fraternity
we might even it you know fraternity and
sorority or at expand a little bit
further like I mentioned those seem to
promise a new world and that's what the
Enlightenment was aiming at a
transformation of human society so it
would become for the first time ever
truly rational truly just truly free and
it turns out that absolute freedom isn't
so easy to grasp now there are two
different ways one could go here one
could say ah see the revolution terrible
idea
we need hierarchy we need this
differentiation in two classes we need
tradition we need we need customs don't
trust abstract rationality by itself
even Burke is a great example of that
all right
and then the traditionalist the the
early traditionalists I understand the
traditionalist means something different
for many people in the present but the
traditionalists before the contemporary
traditionalists were saying that the
French Revolution was a huge mistake and
we need to go back to something prior to
that that's one option
dialectically that is not going to work
instead we move forward we move through
it we see what's on the other side of
this so he goes on and he says what what
was the notion of itself that the
universal will is merely the positive
essence of personality this latter knows
itself
only positively or as preserved therein
but what we find instead of this he says
is self-consciousness which is pure
insight separates it's positive and
negative nature separates the the
predicate lifts absolute what's he
referring to the predicate predicates
list absolute is the divine of the
Enlightenment right into thought and
matter positive and negative so he says
we have pure thought and pure matter so
the here he tells us it's confronted
with the absolute transition of the one
into the other as a present reality this
is where it's very metaphysical and you
might say what is he talking about so
pure thought is the positive here
think about what we mean when we're
talking about pure thought think about
the previous terms that we applied that
to faith which had a Content we're not
talking about that here and then
enlightenment was another form of pure
thought so pure thought the ideology of
the Enlightenment is what
self-consciousness finds at its very
essence as absolute freedom pure thought
there's a transition from that to pure
matter what is pure matter is it simply
atoms quarks you know we have our
physical explanations of these there's
an earlier conception of matter that I
think Hegel has in mind here and when we
talk about pure matter we might have in
mind something like the prime matter
that the Aristotelian 's and then later
Thomas tradition talked about and this
is matter without any properties I mean
it's sort of like you know when when the
lock in his own turn talks about a pure
substratum you know the substance and it
doesn't you know it's just is what it is
and of course the qualities come out of
configurations that it just happens to
have there's an unintelligibility there
and there's a similar unintelligibility
within the social frame
of the kind of death that Hegel has been
raising before our eyes and something to
be terrorized by so he goes on and he
says the universal will qua absolutely
positive actual self consciousness
because it is this conscious reality
heightened to the level of pure thought
or as he says abstract matter what is
the abstract matter its matter
understood in an abstract way that is
through thought in a way it's not really
matter
it's not the matter as it is in itself
so he goes on he says this changes round
into its negative nature and shows it to
be equally that which puts an end to the
thinking of oneself or to self
consciousness what is it that puts an
end to the thinking of itself or self
consciousness here it's death so that
when he's when he's talking in these
essentially allegorical terms about pure
thought and pure matter we have a trends
we have the transition from you know
this is dynamic where there is
consciousness to death and this is very
difficult for a consciousness to
actually wrap its head around
absolute freedom as pure self-identity
of the universal will thus has within it
negation but this means that it contains
difference in general and this again it
develops as an actual difference if
you're pure negativity has in the self
identical Universal will the element of
subsistence or the substance in which
its moments are realized it has the
matter which it can utilize in
accordance with its own determinate Ness
and insofar as the substance has shown
itself to be the negative element for
the individual consciousness the
organization of spiritual masses or
spheres to which the plurality of
individual consciousness is are assigned
the stakes shape once more these
individuals who have felt the fear of
death of their absolute master again
submit to negation and distinctions
arranged themselves in the various
spheres and returned to an apportioned
and limited task but thereby to their
substantial reality
paragraph 593 now describes for us a
dynamic that should be quite familiar to
us as readers of the phenomenology
because we've seen it come up over and
over and over again a sort of hyper
unity giving way to a differentiation
within itself and the conscious person
finding him or herself now within that
no longer the unity but within the
plurality and organized to some degree
plurality which maybe in some you know
transition or conflict but is that going
to be the end of the story why is Hegel
introducing this here you notice in the
paragraph coming after this a very long
paragraph there's gonna be a major
contrast drawn between what seems to be
happening here and what has happened
over and over again in the progress of
consciousness and where we're actually
going so let's chart out what what is
happening he says absolute freedom as
pure self-identity of the universal will
right we've got this universal will
absolute freedom is this pure self
identity who's getting to enjoy the pure
self identity who ever happens to have
power at the time or perhaps it's even
death itself and then this this dynamic
of terror but he says it has within
itself negation it has within itself
negation and Hegel goes on to say ok
that means that it contains difference
because you can't simply negate within a
you know per minute per minute II and
sphere in which all is being nothing is
non being all right
even that betrays itself in the fact
that it's relying upon a grammar and
differentiation within that so Hegel
says we do have negativity leading to
difference but he calls this difference
in general and the term here is actually
intercede which we can translate as
difference but you might
also think in terms of differentiation
you know a sheet is taking place a
splitting a cut a distinguishing of two
things from each other or in this case
many things a multiplicity a plurality
is who's going to say from each other
this difference in general becomes
actual difference view deacon right
vehicle II can intercede it's no longer
just a difference in name a difference
in concept a difference that we could
you know think about and purely
intellectually it's an actual difference
in the world that we live in and you
know this makes perfect sense whatever
absolute freedom is going to be it's
going to need a society which is going
to have to have different parts to it
with different functions and they're
gonna have to be coordinated in some way
so he goes on and he says this means it
contains a you know an actual difference
then it says pure negativity and here it
gets again very metaphysical has in it
the self identical universal will the
element of subsistence or the substance
in which its moments are realized and
now think back to just a few paragraphs
before where we did have all of these
different parts or is going to call them
spiritual masses and spheres and they
all got subsumed into the the society
run by the government representing the
universal will now that's being restored
once the the you know revolutionary
changes have been made
you still need somebody to issue
driver's licenses you still need to make
sure that the crops in the field
actually get to the marketplace we could
go on and on and on with examples so he
says this it has the matter which it can
utilize in accordance with its own
determinant so it's using these
spiritual masses and spheres and these
are not just spiritual guy Stiga mental
these are material to you know the
farmer taking things to market is
actually driving his tractor which needs
gas which you know uses tires that have
to be replaced every so often there are
there all these veer clicker actual real
considerations to bring up so he goes on
and he says in so far here's the key
pay off insofar as this substance has
shown itself to be the negative element
for the individual consciousness so
let's dwell on that
this substance right it's shown itself
to be the negative element for the
individual consciousness it is self
consciousness but it's a particular self
consciousness and it's opposed to the
other self consciousnesses which find
themselves in a certain sense alienated
from that absolute freedom that they get
to see being exercised where do they get
to go they are now forced all back into
these spiritual masses and spheres once
again so in in a certain respect they're
no longer enjoying the status of being
each of them a sort of representative of
the universal will they get to represent
the universal will by giving in to the
actual individual will of whoever's
running the show who speaks for the
universal will and tells them where they
need to be what they need to do he goes
on and he says the organization of
spiritual masses or spheres to which the
plurality of individual consciousnesses
are assigned the stakes shape once more
notice assigned who assigns them to some
degree they could assign themselves you
might say somebody might say I want to
be in the army I want to Cork I want to
stay here on the farm and make food now
for the Revolutionary Government or
something like that but you know
respect what is it that we see
Revolutionary government's doing they
reorganize Society no no don't stay on
the farm we need you in the factory over
here and you know we see
collectivization we see you know people
its users soz for emulation being forced
to be free be free in the way that the
the universal will decides that they
they will be free which may lead to
their own destruction and and not just
destruction but but a Faceman being
taken out of the story altogether
he goes on and he says these individuals
now notice this key phrase these
individuals who felt the fear of death
of their absolute master take that and
put that in your back pocket for right
now but that's going to be very
important they again submit to negation
and distinctions arranged themselves
into the various spheres and return to
an apportioned and limited task but
thereby to their substantial reality
substantial reality is part of the
fabric of society all right
the society that's been gone itself
through the terror and these individuals
have gone through the terror as well and
may still be going through it insofar as
they do return to their apportion tasks
and spheres and and spiritual masses
they can forget that terror for a while
can't they I I'm so glad that all this
you know bloodshed is over now I can get
back to my farm now I can get back to my
bookkeeping now I can go work in that
building you know meet the old meet the
new boss same as the old boss except
he's wearing a revolutionary hat you
know which is great because I already
know how the procedures work so I can
now make them work for this this new
governance the question that lies before
us is does this represent a return to
business
as usual or has something been gained in
the process
you